[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend was ist der
lautstarke und treckerbetriebene Protest
der Landwirte Wert in nackten Zahlen
kann man das noch nicht sagen aber in
warmen Worten denn davon gab es heute
einige so soll es mehr Freiheiten und
weniger Bürokratie geben es soll mehr
Hilfen geben es soll eventuell eine
tierwohlabgabe geben es soll dies und es
soll das geben lauter Konjunktive die
die Bauern auch schon vor vier Jahren
gehört haben an gleicher Stelle in
Berlin doch Zählbares aus Berlin kam
damals nicht wirklich dabei heraus was
sind jetzt also die neuen Andeutungen
Wert und was ist mit der Kürzung der
agrardieselubventionen Fragen dazu
gleich an den Finanzminister also an
Christian Lindner zuvor brittter
Bucholz erst wartet Christian Lindner
eine geschlagene halbe Stunde auf seine
Rede und dann will ihm keiner
zuhören so einen Protest hat er selbst
noch nicht erlebt sprechköre Ohren
betäubend laut
der bauernpräsident meint schließlich
einschreiten zu müssen aber die die er
rief wollen nicht schweigen es ma keinen
Sinn wenn sie nur
ausbuhen zur Demokratie gehört die
Diskussion die Bundesregierung selbst
brachte die Bauern auf die Barrikaden
dabei haben sie eine Idee dass aus der
KFZ Steuer für Traktoren schon wieder
einkassiert nur noch eins soll
bleiben entfällt nicht
sofort die Rückerstattung wird in den
nächsten Jahren nur schrittweise
abgebaut hart bleiben alles andere würde
Politik erpressbar machen nur die
Agrarlobby ist mächtig und nicht nur
Bauern demonstrieren auch Handwerker
Spediteure und viele frustrierte was
braut sich da zusammen Lindner versucht
sich zu verbünden ich bin schon fertig
wenn ich den Pferdestall einmal
ausgemistet habe deshalb weiß ich was
das für eine Arbeit ist es den ganzen
Tag und jeden Tag zu machen hinterher
nimmt der FDP Finanzminister den
Hinterausgang zuhören und verstehen die
Demonstrierenden bleiben
skeptisch wenn man uns in den letzten 5
Jahren mal zugehört hätte da waren viele
Punkte von denen dabei die Lindner heute
in seiner Rede hat und wir haben in den
letzten 5 Jahren vielleicht das Recht
gehabt Anhörung aber nicht des
Gehörtwerdens währenddessen suchen
andere Lösungen im Reichstag treffen die
ampelfaktionschefsvertreter der
Bauernverbände viele Ideen wenig
Konkretes aber das soll noch kommen so
das
Versprechen wir glauben stark genug zu
sein als Parlament als Koalition in den
nächsten Wochen einen so klaren Katalog
auch zu
unterbreiten die Vertreter der
Landwirtschaft wollen demonstrativ
gemeinsam vor die Kamera und zeigen sich
demonstrativ enttäuscht denn ein Ziel
ist für sie nicht
verhandelbar in der eigentlichen
Kernfrage wie gehen wir in Sachen
Agrardiesel weiter haben wir das war
vielleicht auch nicht die Erwartung aber
haben wir noch keine Lösung eine Lösung
diskutiert die Politik seit Jahren die
sogenannte tiervwohlabgabe Milch und
Fleisch würden teurer bisher nicht
durchsetzbar Wunschvorstellung ich würde
mir konkret von Herrn Lindner wünschen
dass er einfach wirklich mal auf meine
Generation schaut auf die Generation die
mutig ist die was bewegen will die für
Klimaschutz für atenvielfalt für
Tierwohl steht und das kann nicht im
Sinne eines Finanzministers sein dass so
die deutsche Landwirtschaft auf die
Ersatzbank gestellt wird wenn hier so
viele Menschen sich einfach abgehängt
fühlen von der
entscheidungslosigkeit einer
Regierung wir
brauchen kuragierte in der
Landwirtschafts und
lebensmittelwirtschaftspolitik damit wir
tatsächlich den Protest von den Straßen
bekommen den Protest von den Straßen
bekommen der Finanzminister wird Ihnen
heute zugehört haben sie sind jedenfalls
unüberhörbar kein leichter Auftritt für
den Finanzminister jetzt folgt ein
weiterer und damit schönen guten Abend
Christian Lindner nach Berlin einen
schönen guten Abend Frau Herr Lindner
warum braucht es so massive Proteste so
ein Schuss vor den Bug bis sie jetzt
wirklich mal ins machen
kommen was meinen Sie damit na ja
zunächst hatten sie Beschlüsse gefasst
dann gab es die Proteste dann sind sie
zurückgerudert bei einer bei einem
Vorhaben dass sie eigentlich machen
wollten jetzt gab es heute das Treffen
mit den Fraktionsvorsitzenden auch da
sind dann verschiedene Dinge jetzt den
Bauern versprochen worden also warum
braucht es all das bis die Politik bis
sie reagieren wir haben zunächst mal
witige Aufgabe beim Bundeshaushalt wir
wollen die Bildung stärken die
Bundeswehr ertüchtigen in Infrastruktur
investieren und bei alldem dürfen die
Steuern nicht erhöht werden wir brauchen
ja einen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung und
wir wollen nicht uferlos neue Schulden
machen denn wir zahlen heute hohen Zins
auf die Staatsverschuldung und deshalb
muss natürlich auch diskutiert werden wo
macht der Staat weniger wo gibt er
weniger Geld aus und ich habe ein
Angebot heute gemacht cht wenn der
Agrardiesel entfällt dann sollten wir
Zug um Zug teure bürokratische Auflagen
für die Landwirtinnen und Landwirte
entfallen lassen damit die eben aus
eigener Kraft auch wirtschaftlich
erfolgreich bleiben können das heißt
beim Agrardiesel ist jetzt tatsächlich
auch noch mal sozusagen
Spiel
nein das heißt ihr Nein steht weil der
Generalsekretär des Bauernverbandes hat
heute noch mal gesagt es gebe
pielraum ich sehe ihn nicht es ist ja
Sache jetzt des haushaltsgesetzgebers
des Deutschen Bundestages aber die
Bundesregierung hat jetzt einen wie ich
finde maßvollen Vorschlag gemacht der
Agrardiesel diese Beihilfe wird jetzt in
den nächsten Jahren schrittweise
entfallen um das mal in eine Relation zu
setzen aus Brüssel und Berlin erhält die
Landwirtschaft jedes Jahr 9 Milliarden
EUR 3% davon fallen 2025 weg und wenn
man sieht was ins insgesamt für den
Haushalt jetzt an Mitteln mobilisiert
wird ist das ein Beitrag aber er ist
fair 1 Milliarde Euro kürzen wir beim
Bürgergeld weil wir Verweigerer
sanktionieren die Politik verzichtet auf
eigene Vorhaben ich habe ja etwa den
Neubau des Finanzministeriums abgesagt
ist also ein ausgewogenes Paket mit dem
Ziel auch neue Dinge zu finanzieren wie
beispielsweise Bildung Bundeswehr
Infrastruktur der Ausbau bzw Weiterbau
beim kanzlerbau ist nicht abgesagt aber
das ist ein anderes Thema es geht ja das
wissen Sie nicht nur um den Agrardiesel
sondern ums grundsätzliche also sprich
um die Wirtschaftlichkeit und auch um
die Zukunftsfähigkeit die kann es nicht
geben solange vier Lebensmittelkonzerne
ihre Marktmacht benutzen und die Preise
bestimmen der Landwirtschaftsminister
aus mekelnburg Vorpommern will jetzt
dass sie mit dem Kartellrecht dagegen
vorgehen wäre das ein Weg das ist eine
Frage die der Wirtschaftsminister prüfen
muss das Kartellamt ist unabhängig und
äh sie sprechen schon den Kern der Frage
an denn es ist nicht der Agrardiesel
sondern es sind ähm Entscheidungen die
über Jahre und Jahrzehnte getroffen
worden sind natürlich muss man die
Marktstrukturen beim Lebensmittel Handel
prüfen aber auf der anderen Seite sehe
ich dass wir sehr viele Vorgaben für die
Landwirtschaft gemacht haben beim
Pflanzenschutz beim Düngen bei der
Tierhaltung bei den
Biokraftstoffen jedes Jahr werden 4% der
landwirtschaftlichen Fläche stillgelegt
stehen also auch nicht für den Ertrag
zur Verfügung und ich verstehe schon
dass jetzt dieser Wirtschaftsbereich
sagt es ist zu viel aber wir können es
nicht lösen über Geld der
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler das
brauchen wir für anderes das ist
begrenzt deshalb ist jetzt die
Gelegenheit die Produktivität und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der Landwirtschaft
zu verbessern dadurch dass wir konkret
an den den kostenträchtigen zu hohen
Auflagen Arbeiten darauf warten die
Landwirte zugegebenermaßen schon lange
jetzt noch mal vielleicht auch
grundsätzlich ja auf die aktuelle
Situation geschaut die Regierung hat
vielen Menschen vor den Kopf gestoßen
das heizungsgesetz Asylpolitik Haushalt
was ist denn eigentlich ihr learning
also erst nachdenken und dann vielleicht
besser
kommunizieren ich glaube dass wir in
sehr kontroversen schwierigen Zeiten
sind wir haben ja Epochen Br in den
letzten Jahren erlebt und hier müssen
schwierige Entscheidungen getroffen
werden offen gesagt müssen auch Dinge
nachgeholt werden die in Deutschland
lange nicht entschieden worden sind
gerade wenn sie die Asylpolitik
ansprechen Frau Hayali wir machen eine
ganz grundlegend neue Realpolitik im
Bereich der Einwanderung
außengrenzenschutz in Europa
Asylverfahren von außerhalb und an der
Außengrenze Grenzschutz in Deutschland
das
Asylbewerberleistungsgesetz wird
geschränk abschiebe Gewahrsam das sind
alles Maßnahmen um die illegale
Migration nach Deutschland zu begrenzen
lange hat es sie nicht gegeben aber Herr
Lindner zur Wahrheit gehört auch dass
sie Entscheidung treffen dann Rudern sie
wieder zurück und sagen dann was anderes
nicht nur Sie sondern das ist im Grunde
Usus fast dieser Regierung und das führt
zu diesem Frust also noch mal was ist
das learning denn
daraus wir haben es mit einer Koalition
unterschiedlicher Parteien zu tun ich
habe großen Respekt davor dass es am
Ende gelungen ist auch die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen der Grünen zu gewinnen für
diese neue Kontrolle bei der
Einwanderung das war auch nicht leicht
für die Grünen aber jetzt am Ende steht
ein Ergebnis eine deutliche zesur
gegenüber der früheren Bundesregierung
bei der Einwanderungspolitik fraglos der
Weg dahin war für manche weit und
schwierig aber jetzt zählt das Ergebnis
der Frust des großes profitiert die laut
Verfassungsschutz in Teilen
rechtsextreme AFD aus unterschiedlichen
Gründen wird da jetzt ein
Verbotsverfahren diskutiert sie lehnen
das ab sie wollen die AFD lieber
inhaltlich stellen da frage ich mich was
haben Sie denn die letzten Jahre gemacht
das ist eine Aufgabe der wir uns alle
stellen müssen ich glaube nur dass ein
Verbot nichts ähm ein verbotverfahren
nichts bringt die Hörde ist sehr hoch
und vor allen den würde der Eindruck
entstehen die Parteien des
demokratischen Zentrums beispielsweise
die FDP hätten Angst vor der
Auseinandersetzung mit der AFD aber wir
haben Antworten ich habe ja gerade schon
geschildert es gibt eine neue
Realpolitik im Bereich der Einwanderung
wir gehen ganz konkret jetzt die
Sanierung des Bundeshaushaltes an
Planungs und Genehmigungsverfahren in
Deutschland werden beschleunigt wir
bereiten eines der größten Pakete zum
Bürokratieabbau vor und das sind ja
alles doch die
twiggerpunkte die die Menschen berühren
und hier muss man klar sagen die AFD
gibt oft einfache aber falsche Antworten
und genau diese Auseinandersetzung in
der Sache muss man suchen ohne die
Wählerinnen und Wähler der AFD in eine
Ecke zu
stellen sagt der Finanzminister
Christian Lindner vielen Dank für das
Gespräch heute Abend gerne danke
Ihnen und das haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet rechtsextreme
sollen unter Beteiligung von AFD
Politikern laut der Wochenzeitung Die
Zeit sieben Geheimtreffen veranstaltet
haben zuletzt eines im November in POZ
dort sollen unter anderem
menschenverachtende Pläne zur
massenhaften Vertreibung von Menschen
besprochen worden sein und genau das hat
jetzt personelle Konsequenzen gunduller
AFD kochchefin Alice Weidel und ihr
persönlicher Referent Roland Hartwig
beenden nach ZDF Informationen mit
sofortiger Wirkung und in gegenseitigem
Einvernehmen ihre Zusammenarbeit
Konsequenz aus hartwigste Teilnahme an
einem Treffen mit rechtsradikalen und
anderen AFD Funktionären in Potzdam im
November gegen die AFD haben am Abend in
Leipzig und auch in Essen erneut
tausende demonstriert zu den Demos
hatten linke und auch bürgerliche
Bündnisse
aufgerufen die deutsche Wirtschaft ist
im vergangenen Jahr in eine Rezession
gerutscht das Bruttoinlandsprodukt sank
gegenüber dem Vorjahr um
0,3% so das Statistische Bundesamt
Hauptgründe die schwache Weltwirtschaft
und die hohe Inflation die den
Privatkonsum bremste
2022 war Europas größte Volkswirtschaft
noch um
1,8% gewachsen
über die massiven Finanzprobleme der
Krankenhäuser hat Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach mit Vertretern von Kommunen
und Landkreisen beraten dabei forderten
diese erneut schnellere und höhere
Milliardenhilfen als vom Bund geplant
für ihre ihre Krankenhäuser Lauterbach
nutzte das Treffen um die
unionsgeführten Länder zur Zustimmung
zum Krankenhaus Transparenzgesetz zu
drängen daran sein schnelle Hilfen für
die Kliniken gebunden als Vorstufe für
die geplan große
krankenhausreform Angehörige der aus
Israel verschleppten Geiseln haben die
Bundesregierung um erneute Hilfe gebeten
um die Entführten freiubekommen
deutschland solle dazu auf den
Vermittler Qatar Einwirken auf Schloss
belvue wurden die Angehörigen der
Geiseln von Bundespräsident Steinmeier
empfangen 100 Tage nach dem Angriff der
Hamas auf Israel einige der
Verschleppten haben die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft oder familiäre
Bindungen nach
Deutschland die in Iran inhaftierte
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin narges
Mohammadi ist ihren Angehörigen zu Folge
zu weiteren 15 Monaten Haft verurteilt
worden wegen angeblicher Propaganda
gegen das System die
51-Jährige
Menschenrechtsaktivistin setzt sich
gegen die Unterdrückung von Frauen in
Iran und für die Abschaffung der
Todesstrafe ein der
Friedensnobelpreis wurde an ihre Kinder
gegeben sie sitzt im Gefängnis
verurteilt bereits zu mehr als 30 Jahren
Haft
Donald Trump hat im republikanischen
kandidatenrennen jedes einzelne TV-Duell
in den letzten Monaten ausgelassen und
am liebsten würde er das bei den
präsidentschaftsvorwahlen genauso
handhaben denn in seinem
Selbstverständnis ist er ja der
Auserwählte dass er dennoch gewählt
werden muss ist für jemanden wie Trump
für den es ja im Grunde auch nur Trump
gibt fast schon eine Zumutung vom
stschuss der Vorwahlen aus Iowa Elma
Tissen vermutlich brennen sie von innen
für ihren Kandidaten Donald Trump bei
-30° Celsus ist Schlange stehen für über
eine Stunde nicht ganz ungefährlich
Blake mannell trägt heute mauerstiel nur
Donald Trump könne die Grenze zur Mauer
dicht machen alle anderen auch beiden
seien viel zu
schwach Donald Trump ist der einzige der
unser Land retten
kann vor aber alles unter 50% wäre
enttäuschend ihr dürft nicht zu Hause
bleiben selbst wenn ihr euch hundeelend
fühlt oder nach der Stimmabgabe sterbt
ist es das
wert ja das Wetter könnte die
Wahlbeteiligung drücken vielleicht würde
es Nicki Haley helfen wenn die
exgouverneurin von South Carolina danach
unbotschafterin hier auf Platz 2 landet
entsteht so etwas wie Momentum denn nach
Umfragen hätte sie bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl noch bessere
Chancen Joe Biden zu schlagen als Donald
Trump never backd niemals nachgeben ein
Song eigens geschrieben für Ron
desanttis er galt einmal als einzig
ernstzunehmender Konkurrent für Trump
könnte hier jedoch hinter hay auf Platz
3 landen ich will jemanden der nicht auf
Rache aus ist nicht auf
Bösartigkeiten aber als etwas nettere
Version von Trump könnte desantes hier
scheitern auch wenn er beteuert nur er
könne bei den republikanischen vor mit
Trump
mitteil tatsächlich sieht er
mittlerweile Nicki Haley als
gefährlichste Gegnerin vor allem wenn
sie hier zweite würde und in newampchire
nächste Woche vielleicht gar
erste es ist eklig draußen sagt der so
ist es auch in Leon 1800 Einwohner in
einem der ärmsten Landkreise von Iowa im
B den der Bärenhöhle will nur einer mit
uns reden John Wilson Veteran der us
Trump Anhänger mach die Grenze dicht
sonst zerbricht das Land wenn es nicht
schon zerbrochen ist Wilson sorgt sich
um
Amerika ich habe eine riesen Angst er
kann nicht weiter reden muss ich erst
einmal
fangen es ist einfach nicht mehr das
Land in dem ich aufgewachsen
bin wie gesagt sie brennen hier für
Trump als Retter auch wenn seine Gegner
noch so oft behaupten wenn er wirklich
wiederkmt sei die Freiheit in Amerika
bedroht ein Mann der mit seiner Energie
spaltet wir kümmern uns jetzt aber um
eine andere Energie eine die nicht durch
Spaltung sondern durch Fusion entstehen
soll der Kernfusion in den
energiepolitischen Debatten ist sie
plötzlich wieder im Gespräch vielleicht
auch weil es im vorletzten Jahr in den
USA einen ganz kleinen Durchbruch gab
jedenfalls will z.B die neue häische
Landesregierung diesen Forschungsbereich
tatsächlich wieder stärker fördern
Vorbild für die Kernfusion ist die Sonne
über den Stand der Forschung Christian
Kirsch die Sonne welch ein Kraftwerk
kaum erschöpfliche Energie diese
Kraftquelle auf die Erde zu holen das
versuchen Sie hier TU Darmstadt ein
Labor des jungen Unternehmens focused
energy Professor rot und sein Team
wollen den sonnenreaktor auf der Erde
zünden Kernfusion eine Hoffnung für den
immer
energiehungrigeren Planeten ich denke
langfristig ist die Kernfusion nicht nur
eine Chance für uns alle sondern
langfristig wird die Kernfusion die
Energieform sein die die Menschheit ins
nächste Jahrhundert bringen wird
einerseits ist es eine Energieform die
ständig zur Verfügung steht die wir also
immer dann an und abschalten können wenn
wir sie brauchen anders als die
fluktuierenden Energieformen der
erneuerbaren Energien und zum anderen
ist es die letzte Energieform die die
Menschheit sich noch nicht erschlossen
hat die Idee der Kernfusion Deuterium
und trizium also schwerer und
überschwerer Wasserstoff werden unter
Druck und ungeheurer Hitze miteinander
verschmolzen diesen Prozess sollen Laser
starten dabei entstehen Helium ein
Neutron und vor allem eine Menge
Energie die Forschungsanlage ita in
Südfrankreich nahe Marseille 5000
Menschen bauen hier an einem
Fusionsreaktor ein Dom der Wissenschaft
extrem heißes Plasma in Magneten soll
die heliumfusion auslösen doch die
Anlage wird und wird nicht startklar
vielleicht vermuten manche in der
Forschung ist die Magnettechnik schon
vor dem Start
überholt Dubai im Dezember auf dem
Weltklimagipfel schließen sich unter
Führung der usa5 sten zusammen um
gemeinsam weiter an der Kernfusion zu
forschen wir stehen nah an einer
fusionsgetriebenen Wirklichkeit es gibt
weiterhin große wissenschaftliche und
technische Herausforderungen und
umsichtige Politik ist von Nöten in
diesem kritischen
Moment auch Deutschland forscht weiter
das Projekt Wendelstein 7x in
Greifswald soll durch einen sogenannten
stellererator die Magnettechnologie
verbessert werden das Ziel auch hier die
etwa 100 Millionen Grad zu erreichen die
es zur Zündung der Fusion auf der Erde
braucht in Darmstadt setzt man
stattdessen auf den Einsatz von Lasern
dass das Ganze physikalisch auf der Erde
möglich ist ist erwiesen nun muss ein
neues Ziel erreicht werden mehr Energie
gewinnen als in die Zündung investiert
wird wir haben uns überlegt dass wir
einen ersten Demonstrator bis zum Ende
der 30er Jahre fertig haben wollen der
tatsächlich bereits in der Lage ist
Strom zu produzieren das wäre dann ein
System auf der man aufbauen dann
Fusionskraftwerke bauen könnte und in
alle Welt exportieren könnte das heißt
wir reden von einem Zeithorizont Ende
der 30er Jahre bis die ersten
Fusionskraftwerke gebaut werden können
Kernfusion ob es funktionieren wird ist
weiter unklar jedenfalls eine
Chance ja und ein Markt der auf
günstigen Strom in großen Mengen jetzt
schon aber erst recht in Zukunft sehr
angewiesen ist ist ja der der
E-Mobilität und Gundula da tut sich ein
bisschen was jawohl Elektroautos fast
aller Marken werden günstiger die
Hersteller gleichen die weggefallene
Förderung für E-Autos aus und passen
ihre Preise an wir fragen wallerie
Haller womit können Kunden in etwa
rechnen was heißt das konkret ja also
Autoexperte Bratzel rechnet im Schnitt
mit 15% Nachlass wobei die Autobauer
natürlich auch die Preispolitik der
Konkurrenz beobachten dass die
Hersteller mit Rabatten reagieren davon
kann man tatsächlich ausgehen die
staatliche Förderung die sogenannte
Umweltprämie ist weggefallen und
Hersteller versuchen diese mit
Nachlässen zu kompensieren trotz der
reabatte dürfte der Verkauf von stromern
dieses Jahr eher schwierig werden meinen
Experten das von der Bundesregierung
ausgerufene Ziel bis zum Jahr
15 Millionen E-Autos auf die Straße zu
bringen halten viele jedenfalls für
unrealistisch und trotzdem eine stabile
ladesäuleninfrastruktur wird immer
dringlicher jetzt hat ein großer
Tankstellenbetreiber die Probleme erneut
adressiert genau das war Aral aber nicht
nur Aral auch Experten von Siemens und
andere meinen Strom gibt es in der Regel
genug Schwachpunkt sind eher die
Verteilnetze die nicht immer in der Lage
sind mehrere Ladevorgänge gleichzeit zu
versorgen ohne zu überlasten das gilt
vor allem für den ländlichen Raum daher
fordern Experten schon lange der
ladesäulenausbau muss einhergehen mit
dem Ausbau der
Netzinfrastruktur ein weiteres Problem
sind die Trafos für die schnelladesäulen
deren Genehmigung dauert laut Aral bis
zu Z Jahre viel zu lang wenn der Umstieg
auf mehr E-Mobilität gelingen soll
vielen Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt mehrere Apotheken in Deutsch
stehen unter Verdacht das vom Staat
bereitgestellte coronamedikament
paxlovid illegal weiterverkauft zu haben
nach Angaben verschiedener
Staatsanwaltschaften gibt es mehrere
Strafanzeigen des
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums gegen
Apotheker das relativ teure paxlovid
sollte Patienten mit Vorerkrankungen
kostenlos zur Verfügung gestehen und
durfte nicht an Dritte weiterverkauft
werden das Unwort des Jahres 2023 lautet
Remigration damit kritisiert die Jury
dass der aus der migrations und
Exilforschung stammende Begriff von
rechten Parteien und rechtsextremen
Gruppierungen als beschönigende
tarnvokabel missbraucht werde für die
Forderung Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte massenhaft
zwangsweise auszuweisen aktuell wird
über den Begriff im Zusammenhang des
Treffens in Potzdam von Rechtsextremen
und AFD Politikern
diskutiert als vor kurzem ein Vulkan auf
Island ausbrach gab es etliche Berichte
faszinierende Bilder und sogar einen
permanenten Livestream jetzt ist der
Vulkan erneut ausgebrochen das heißt
also zum zweiten Mal innerhalb von vier
Wochen und erneut musste das kleine Dorf
grinderwig evakuiert werden der
Unterschied zum ersten Ausbruch dieses
Mal sind die Lavaströme näher am
bewundten Gebiet so nah sogar dass Lava
schon Häuser in Brand gesetzt hat Henna
Hebestreit es ist eine Fahrt durch
unsicheres Terrain 10 km geht es durch
eine wilde Landschaft bis ins
Vulkangebiet rund um grinderwig hier
lebten einmal 4000 Menschen immerhin 1%
der Bevölkerung Islands jetzt sind sie
auf der Flucht vor den Gewalten der
Natur ein paar Schritte von den Häusern
entfernt hat sich buchstäblich die Erde
aufgetan Lava strömt in den Ort
verbrennt und verschlingt mehrere
Häuser das was unserer Heimatstadt
gerade passiert ist traurig wir selbst
sind sicher aber die Unsicherheit bleibt
wir wissen nicht wie es weitergeht und
das ist gerade ganz schlimm
über Nacht hat sich die Natur allerdings
etwas beruhigt der Druck scheint erst
einmal aus dem unterirdischen Kessel
entwichen zu sein nur noch wenige
Lavafontänen dringen an die Oberfläche
gut zu sehen die Frische langsam
erstarrende Lava aber unberechenbar ist
sie immer
noch unter der dunklen Oberfläche die
Sie hier sehen fließt immer noch glühend
heiße Lava die kann jederzeit wieder
durch die dünne Decke austreten da muss
man auf Abstand bleiben außerdem treten
gefährliche giftige Gase
aus aktuell aber drückt die Lava nicht
mehr so mächtig voran die Hoffnung ist
groß dass die massiven erdwelle die sie
zum Schutz aufgetürmt hatten dem
tödlichen gesteinsbrei erstmal
standhalten auch er hatte sich hinter
den Wellen in Sicherheit gewähnt
Dokumentarfilmer Heiko helltorf hatte
dutzende Einwohner von grinderwig bei
der Rückkehr in ihren Ort begleitet als
sie in der Nacht zu Sonntag plötzlich
wieder fliehen
mussten da war so ein bisschen
Enttäuschung in der Luft und eigentlich
auch schon fast
äh die Befürchtung das konnte man denen
ansehen dass sie nie wieder zurückkommen
den experten schließen nicht aus dass
schon bald wieder solche Lavaströme
fließen rund um grinderwig
800 Jahre war still bis 2021 und jetzt
immer wieder auch ein bisschen verrückt
na ja hier gibt es wie jeden Werktag
einen heute journal Update heute um 015
Uhr mit Christopher wermann von uns
war's das für heute und sagen machen sie
es gut wo auch immer sie sind bis
[Musik]
mor guten Abend das Tief das uns heute
Schnee und Glätte brachte zieht morgen
weiter nach Osten dann kommt ein kleines
Zwischenhoch und in der Nacht zu
Mittwoch und Mittwoch über Tag bringt
dieses tief über dem Atlantik eine
Warmfront das bedeutet milde Luft
schiebt sich über die Eiseskälte am
Boden das bedeutet gefährlicher
Glatteisregen und Schneefall
Schneeschauer gibt's auch heute Nacht
besonders hier im Norden und Nordosten
Deutschlands einige Schneeschauer kann
es auch am Alpenrand geben sonst ist es
im Süden meist trocken und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 1° an der
Nordsee und bis -11° überb Schnee am
Alpenrand die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen meist um den Gefrierpunkt und
auch morgen kann es hier in norddeutsch
noch für einige Schneeschauer reichen
sonst wird das ein freundlicher Dienstag
bevor dann in der Nacht auf Mittwoch und
Mittwoch über Tag Eisregen Schnee und
Regen heranziehen es kann besonders im
Westen und in den Mittelgebirgen über
Stunden diesen gefährlichen Eisregen
geben oder Schnee 20 30 cm Neuschnee
sind möglich es kann auch schneewehungen
geben also vermeidbare Wege sollten Sie
wirklich Unterlassen von all dem
bekommen sie in Norddeutschland nichts
mit da wird der Mittwoch freundlich es
wird markant milder im Südwesten mit bis
zu 11° am Mittwoch und am Donnerstag
ziehen Schnee und Regen weiter nach
Süden der Freitag wird dann für uns alle
wieder recht freundlich bei
Höchsttemperaturen von -2 bis + 4° guten
Abend